vamos a pensar un poco que significa que
algo sea un múltiplo de un número así
que nos preguntan cuál de los siguientes
números es múltiplo de 9
pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrarlo
muy bien ahora vamos a hacerlo juntos y
cuando pensamos en un múltiplo nos
referimos a un número que puedes obtener
al multiplicar el número en este caso 9
por un número entero por ejemplo podemos
saber los múltiplos de 9 si contamos
salteado esta es una forma de hacerlo
así que vamos de 9 a 18 a 27 a 36 a 45 a
54 a 63 a 72 a 81 y puedes seguir y
seguir pero para saber si estos números
son múltiplos o no realmente lo que
necesitamos decir es oye alguno de estos
números está en esta lista ahora si uno
de estos números es más grande que 81
entonces tendremos que seguir contando
salteado hasta ver si lo incluye o no
primero podemos ver que 46 se encuentra
entre dos múltiplos de 946 es más
cercano de 45 pero
entre 45 y 54 está entre dos múltiplos
de nueve por lo tanto no será un
múltiplo otra forma de pensarlo es que
un número es múltiplo si al dividirlo
entre 9 no obtiene residuo pero si
divides 46 entre 9 vas a obtener un
residuo así que tampoco serás capaz de
dividir 9 entre el de igual manera bien
lo voy a descartar de la contienda y
después dice 77 éste está justo aquí
entre 72 y 81 y una vez más está entre
dos múltiplos pero no es múltiplo 39
está entre 36 y 45 de igual manera está
entre dos múltiplos pero no sus
múltiplos y podemos ver que claramente
18 es un múltiplo si estoy haciendo esto
por mi cuenta
podría contar salteado en mi cabeza y
decir ok 99 19 18 bien aquí tenemos un
18 especialmente cuando nos dicen que
elijamos solamente una respuesta
y entonces esta sería nuestra respuesta
correcta bien hagamos otro ejemplo
cuál de los siguientes incisos muestra
solo múltiplos de 8 elige una respuesta
bien pausa el vídeo y piensa un poco en
esto
bien podemos ir revisando inciso por
enciso así que veamos en el primer
inciso tengo 4 es múltiplo de 8 bueno 4
puede dividir a 8 podemos decir que 8 es
un múltiplo de 404 no es un múltiplo de
8 ya que porque el número entero
tengo que multiplicar a 8 para obtener a
4 por ninguno así que fácilmente podemos
cancelar este inciso y puedes ver de
hecho que esto lo que nos muestra son
múltiplos de cuatro no múltiplos de ocho
y podemos contar salteado 4 8 12 16 20
24 28
estos son los múltiplos de cuatro no
múltiplos de 8
observa que algunos múltiplos de cuatro
son múltiplos de 8 8 es múltiplo de 8 16
es múltiplo de 8 24 es múltiples de 8
pero no todos los múltiplos de cuatro
son múltiplos de 8 de hecho creo que
puedes ver aquí un patrón sobre cuáles
sí y cuáles no son múltiplos de 8 bien
inciso 2 16 es lo mismo que 8 por 2 24
es lo mismo que 8 por 3 32 es lo mismo
que 8 por 4 y 40 es lo mismo que 8 por 5
en efecto podemos contar salteado 8 16
24 32 40 después 48 56 y seguir y seguir
y seguir todos estos son múltiplos de 8
así que seleccionaré este inciso
y por último tengo 12 4 8 bueno estos
son números que pueden dividir a 8 y no
dejar residuos puedes pensar los como
los factores de 8 observa si multiplicas
1 por 8 obtienes 8 y puedes multiplicar
4 por 2 y obtener también 8 pero estos
no son múltiplos de 8 ya que porque el
número entero tengo que multiplicar a 8
para obtener 1 o para obtener 2 o para
obtener 4 por ninguno en general los
múltiplos de un número van a ser ese
número con números más grandes que él
estaba a punto de decir ese número
múltiplos de él pero eso no tiene
sentido porque esa es la definición de
un múltiplo no puedes utilizar múltiple
como la definición de múltiplo pero eso
si los múltiplos de un número van a ser
ese número o números más grandes que
eres
y si quieres contar salteado con base en
ese número obtendrás todos los múltiplos